hmm a Judoon platoon coming soon so
first concrete news about what is coming
in series 12 of Doctor Who has hit and
it's the big rhinos from space so now
one of them's got a mohawk
now I actually initially when I saw that
this sort of I was gonna say lead it
didn't leak it was dropped officially
it's it's an officially released bit of
information I didn't think I was really
gonna have any thoughts about it but
then the more I thought about it the
more I'm like no actually I actually do
kind of have some thoughts about this so
first off if they're going to hint at
the return of previously introduced I'm
just gonna say creature not necessarily
villain cuz the Judoon are a little
weird like that but I'll come back to
that fact the Judoon er is just a good
pick for that for a couple of reasons
the first is is that they have as I said
they've never had as distinctly defined
a role as many of the recurring
characters so giving us a reveal of them
coming back is actually not spoiling as
much as showing say a Dalek or a
Cyberman or the silence or a weeping
angel because those characters and those
creatures in those monsters are so
defined by what they do and their roles
in a story and sort of how those stories
tend to play out our pretty set knots
that you can never deviate on them but
like if we see some of them then we know
certain things that we are absolutely
going to be dealing with then by
contrast with the Judoon you can drop
the Judoon into almost any kind of story
and give them some kind of role in it
the episode might not even Center on the
Judoon at all but you can still get that
little pop get that little tease of
going here we are bringing back some
older characters also I think it's a
good call to drop these guys as
as an early tease because it comes
across a bit less desperate because
knowing the mixed reception to series 11
and yes I'm just gonna go with mix I'm
not gonna rehash the arguments about
what did or didn't work about the series
but let's just go with the reception was
mixed and leave it at that
don't fight me on it please and if they
had come in in the first thing that
showed us was a Dalek was the master was
Omega was well maybe not Omegan that's
just for me but you know was a Cyberman
that that would have come across as a
lot more pandering because that's like
oh my god please here's the stuff we
know you love but with the Judoon it it
it feels like a really good balance and
I'm not necessarily saying to use them
I'm saying to to reveal them so this
isn't necessarily a praise of whatever a
pre-emptive praise of whatever episode
they're going to appear in but it is a
praise on the marketing this feels very
finely calculated I actually mean that
as a compliment because marketing like
creative decisions they shouldn't be
overly calculated based on what the
reception are gonna be because you end
up with very compromised stories that
way marketing decisions really should be
carefully calculated I feel like this
was a very well calculated decision what
is a what is a creature that has been in
the show before that we can bring back
get a little pop but that is not also
going to come across as us either
desperate for approval or who is just
showing them is gonna give away the game
of like what kind of episode this is
gonna be and I think did you do gnar
honestly kind of perfect for that
so props to BBC's publicity Department I
guess which that's the sentence I didn't
think I'd be saying today but having now
said that let's actually talk about the
Judoon in general and I do like the
Judoon
but I liked what they were in their
first appearance better than what
they've kind of been since which
actually happens rather a lot with
Doctor Who villains weeping angels and
the silence
to mine but what I mean by that is
having fairly recently re-watched
smithing Smith and Jones the detail that
not only do I think fans tend to forget
but the show for God is that it's not
just that they are police of some form
the doctor actually actually identifies
the morris police for hire their goons
and yet when they appeared later like
when when one of them showed up in the
Sarah Jane Adventures now I will admit
my memory on this is slightly hazy I
didn't go back and re-watch this episode
before shooting this video I don't have
that kind of time in my life but it the
running gag was he as he came to
understand what the laws of Earth where
he started rigidly enforcing those laws
as well which doesn't quite line up
because he's got no investment or reason
to do that and they started being
portrayed as much more just they follow
the law absolutely which doesn't feel
quite right versus what we got initially
because the thing was they actually they
what they basically did was they
illegally extradited an entire Hospital
from the planet to the moon so that they
could search it and they probably should
not have been able to do that now on a
technicality maybe that was something
that was not specifically forbidden but
that to me is the essence of the Judoon
that I want to see explored more it's
not just that they are law enforcement
and like if they showed up again just
with the with the shadow Proclamation
but you can't just reinforce the idea
there's just oh well they're just really
strict police I'm like no there there
there's something a little bit more
mercenary about them than that because
what the the read that I got on the
especially re-watching Smith and Jones
is they obey the letter of the law not
because they believe in the absolute
rightness of the law but because obeying
the letter of the law insulate
the shady stuff that they're doing if
you know the law well enough that you
can stick within technically within the
bounds of what is or is not allowed but
still go very much against the spirit of
the law I feel like that is the Judoon
or it's what they were in their first
appearance and it's what I would like to
see them be again because like the whole
idea that they go there and they you
know the instant somebody is even
honestly just openly scared of them they
they execute him so and again probably
technically within the bounds of the
laws they're operating on but like him
that's not in the spirit of the law
serve and protect like frigging hell and
you know they're prepared to leave all
of these people even though they were
like well initially they only kill them
if they're interfering with the
investigation but then later they're not
going to help them and they're just
gonna leave them in a situation where
they're all going to die and they are
happy to do that just because they're
not the ones who created the situation
that is going to kill all these people
so again letter of the law not the
spirit of it and I would like to see
that played for more sinister
machinations as opposed to a bit more
comedic Lee which is what happened like
I said would like the Sarah Jane
Adventures appearance now I also have to
admit I haven't seen any of the non show
appearances of the Judoon I know they've
shown up I think in a novel and possibly
in a big finish here there so I don't
know what angle any of that was coming
at them from I just don't want them to
be used as like oh the the big dumb
rhinos who just talked really you know
oh so no Shobo know like like yes that
was kind of cute and it was yeah you
know it was funny that you know they
made David Tennant and trying yo speak
that back to them like I'm not saying
that wasn't fun but like dig into what
they actually are by design and find
something interesting to do with them or
conversely just have them briefly appear
in a story about something else
that's also totally fine because I don't
like the Judoon so much that I need an
entire story built around them I'd be
happy just to see them here like oh yeah
there we go because I think that's that
that's something that a good
interconnected world does when they when
it becomes big enough so the way sort of
you interconnect the history and the
elements and the characters and the
creatures from a world like this the way
that I dislike it is when it feels like
something that is a callback to
something previously shows up and it
feels like it's meant to be a big yeah I
recognize that thing but like there's no
reason for it to be there it's just
there for the connection it's there for
the pop from the audience and it serves
no purpose otherwise that will drive me
crazy what I think works really well is
when you basically come up with the
stories like cool and then you realize
oh there's there's a character here
that's filling this story required role
we created a new character hang on I
think we might actually already have a
character like that who exists can we
use them in this hang on let me check
and you check in from oh yeah no we
could totally use the character we
already know to do this so that the role
is still strictly functional but you get
that little at a pop of like oh cool
interconnected thing so like I'd be
perfectly fine with the Judoon filling
that kind of role in this story where
maybe there's just like a point in the
story where the doctor needs to run into
authority figures of some form and hey
why not have it be the Judoon cool I'd
be down for that too but yeah like I
said I had my I saw it I'm like okay
Moloch and I thought that was gonna be
the end of my thoughts but like my brain
kept working over it and I had more
thoughts thought I'd share them here so
the Judoon returning to series 12 your
thoughts on that what other creatures
would you like to see come back what or
what is a what is a sort of I'm for lack
of a better term I'm just gonna call it
lower tier creature you know not one of
the big marquee ones that you would like
to see come back young that good that I
put like on a similar level to the
Judoon whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about a whole bunch of stuff to do
because there's buttons and links and
there's a link to the patreon which any
support you're able to lend even a
dollar a month is incredibly helpful and
it gives you access to voting on topics
and there are other tier Awards they get
you the discord names with the credits
whole bunch of stuff
plus there's merch plus there's links
they take you places click on them or
don't because at the end of the day
folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]